any time there is a massive news story
as Monumental as the arrest of a former
president of the United States you have
your main story and then you have sort
of subsidiary stories and then you have
secondarily subsidiary stories one of
those secondarily subsidiary stories
that has caught the eye and ear of many
of you is what is going on with attorney
Alan dershowitz and Trump's former
personal attorney Michael Cohen now to
give you the background on this Michael
Cohen friend of the show good guy he
used to be Trump's fixer he was directly
involved in the Stormy Daniels hush
money payments he served prison time for
his involvement in those crimes which
now Trump is is being indicted for and
Alan dershowitz is a historically
left-wing lawyer who has really started
to become a darling of the right
regularly appearing on Fox News and
Newsmax and Steve bannon's show as a
defender of trump legally and dershowitz
is always quick to say listen I voted
again Trump and I look forward to voting
against him again but this is so unfair
and that's so unfair and he's being
treated so unfairly the new thing and
this is this is just unbelievable stuff
dershowitz says he's going to sue
Michael Cohen okay this started last
week with dershowitz on Fox News I'm
going to take you through the entire
story dershowitz on Fox news said
Michael Cohen tweeted that I was
involved with underage girls on Jeffrey
Epstein's Island and now Michael Cohen's
going to be in trouble so this is the
start of the story here's dershowitz on
Fox shooting together two inapplicable
statutes and using Michael Cohn let me
tell you something about Michael Kong
he's not through with his problems he
just tweeted about me saying because I
had attacked his credibility that I was
involved with underage girls on
Epstein's Island I'm about to sue him
now for defamation as you know the woman
who falsely accused me acknowledged that
she may have made a mistake in
misidentifying me and I would normally
not sue somebody for I'm just gonna Sue
usually I wouldn't but I'm gonna Sue
writing that kind of nonsense but this
is Michael
try to
Donald Trump from running for president
of the United States single-handedly
for defamation not let him get away with
that and when I sue him I will be able
to prove his repeated lies because he
can't refuse to testify in a civil case
so his problems are just beginning I'm
going to make it a little easier for Joe
jackpoto to tattoo to uh did he say Joe
jackapina
as I've said before any first year
up and if it wasn't in Manhattan this
case has to get out of Manhattan all
right so there is dershowitz saying he
will be suing Michael Cohen then he
appears on Alex Jones Show and again
when we talk about the downfall of Alan
dershowitz in a Time past
dershowitz would never even consider
appearing on the program of someone like
propagandist Alex Jones it would just be
out what no of course I'm not appearing
on Alex Jones Show but here is
dershowitz almost pretending like it's a
normal show saying he is indeed suing
Michael Cohen Rob start over you're
gonna assume Michael Cohen that's that's
big news please tell us
your defamation and then the question
that if he takes the witness stand he'll
be asked you say you started telling the
truth but you just lied about Alan
dershowitz you know he wasn't on Epstein
sound you know he's never had sex with
an underage girl he's just got mad at
him because he called you a liar so you
made up a story about him so you're
still lying right I wasn't going to get
around that yeah so durso it's very soon
will be really inconveniencing Michael
Cohen I guess and then again later
continuing to follow the threat of this
story dershowitz finishing the rounds by
appearing on Steve bannon's program on
real America's voice and he says you
know after I threatened to sue Michael
Cohen Michael Cohen texted me and said
I'll take the Tweet down but their show
it's doesn't care he's still going to
sue if he apologized or took it down or
would you back off that are you going to
go after him hard on this well let me
read you the email he just sent to me
Alan as you know from our conversation
on my podcast I have and has always had
had tremendous respect in admiration for
you as a constitutional lawyer and
Scholar if you were angered at my tweet
why not just have called me and express
that to me I am happy to remove the
tweet I am happy to remove the Tweet but
similarly I ask that you treat me with
the same respect that I treat you feel
free to call me at any time well he's
willing to remove the Tweet that's not
enough you know when when you throw a
skunk into the Jury Room you can take
the skunk out but the smell Still
Remains he accused me of associating
with a pedophile on an island with young
people it's just a total and complete
and categorical line well now see now
I'm confused I my understanding was that
dershowitz was saying is it's true he
did associate with Epstein but he said
probably never did anything specific
involving underage girls now in any case
my prediction other than Alan dershowitz
never recovers his reputation my
prediction is that Alan dershowitz
doesn't Sue because if he were to sue
Michael Cohen for defamation whatever
the outcome would be dershowitz would be
subject to Discovery and examination and
even if it's true that dershowitz was
never involved with young whatever
I don't think Alan dershowitz at this
point wants to have to answer questions
under oath about his relationship with
Jeffrey Epstein so call me crazy I don't
expect dershowitz to Sue I could be
wrong I'm terrible at predictions we
will follow it and we will see